it looks like apple september iphone 14
launch event is happening on september
7th which is a wednesday which sounds
really weird because i usually do it on
tuesday but labor day is on that monday
so tuesday is apparently a travel day
according to mark german who is the most
reliable apple leaker so in terms of
what to expect we should expect the new
iphone 14 lineup which is going to get
rid of the mini model and give us a new
regular 14 larger model like the pro max
we're also getting three new apple
watches which is the se2 the regular
series 8 and the new apple watch pro
which is going to be insane with a new
design and awesome battery life and we
thought we were going to be getting a 10
generation ipad but it looks like that's
getting delayed until october and as far
as the airpods pro 2 that might not come
because mark german did not mention it
in his brand new report but either way
those new iphones and apple watches are
going to be insane on september 7th